I used to love going to strip clubs I
used to go all the time and I just don't
anymore I mean I haven't been in so well
I think I went two years ago with my
wife and some
friends and it was to that place on the
body shop in the body shop uh on Sunset
and that place used to be awesome and I
guess it's I don't know I've gone once
but a f it caught fire and then
it and and then it [__] it's not been
the same one time I was in the strip
club and I was with a uh a buddy of mine
we went to we went to a strip club and
he went back to get a lap dance and he
went with the worst
one and I'm talking about this was
in deep North
Hollywood okay for people that aren't in
Hollywood they don't even know there's a
North Hollywood hey guys there's a North
Hollywood they know West Hollywood wood
they might not but they don't know North
Hollywood well guess what there is one
all right and it's riddled with you
know
like checks cash places and bail bonds
and strip clubs okay we went one to one
and he oh man it was so funny dude he
was
like we went to the strip club it was me
him and another guy and
we were like wow that one's like crazy
but you was hustling you know what I'm
talking about the the the the the I
guess I would say the worst looking you
are as a stripper the more you got to be
a every day I'm hustling every day I'm
hustling every day I'm Every Day I'm
every day I'm
hustling just on the [__] pole and
that was a banger at the strip club too
just chicks come out with you know 16
teeth just pearshaped every day I'm h
every day every day like well yeah she
needs to you know and then a [__]
dope
ass just bodied out caramel sunde comes
out and you're just like that's the one
but
anyway just a beautiful [__]
hourglass shaped cookies and cream just
walsing out and you're oh you know they
do that [__] to that one
song they come out
to they come out to that
[Laughter]
[Music]
song [__] dude some por his head my god
dude if you want to hook up with a chick
and you're in a room with her and you're
single and she's chilling and she's got
no interest in it all you got to do is
pour some wine and just play a little
bit of porise head and dude get the
towels
[Music]
out darling I'll be right back I'm going
to the bathroom to grab some
towels cuz the fine chicks either dance
to that
or
so seductive that
one anyway
um so the the the the ugly ones come out
to every day I'm hustling you know
because they have to and [__] so she
came out we were just like oh god dude
it was like Friday we're like damn you
know and
uh sure enough dude she [__] hustled
my friend so hard I went back with some
[__] you know she swindled me out of
some money I remember I would go to the
strip club and the [__] the the
awesome the best looking
one would [__] go back I'd give her
the cash and then she'd be like you only
give me this and she would hide some of
the money and I I knew it but I was like
all right here you go uh I saw her like
recently like a year or two ago and she
wow looks awful I just saw her walking
around so that's what you get
swindling uh
anyway he went back with um so every
time I think of when I think of American
male this is what going back to goddamn
it I mean I'm so devolving this whole
[__] podcast
but he I'm getting a dance with the
[__] good one and then I come out and
I'm like where the hell's my friend and
my other friend says you're not going to
believe this he went back with the
[__] Rick Ross dancing ass girl and I
go
what dude he comes out after a few
minutes just on his face just shame you
know and he says the he starts off the
conversation
with well I didn't want to but and
we dude we had to sit down because
nothing's funnier than that you
understand
you you didn't want to oh hey but guy
you dead you know if you don't want it
don't go I didn't want to but and dude
we we we immediately sat down tears
before laughing because it was that
funny when we just had to explode you
know and he was like and she and she
convinced me to go back and then I did
and then she was like it's going to be
so good and and then and then and then
and then dude he was back there and she
was she was grinding on
him and and she was like he explained
that he her butt was on his out his
penis was out you know and I was like
God damn dude all right you
know and he was like and I sh dude he
says and I finally went when I just this
is how we talk when I just it shot it
shot over her ass it shot over her ass
and dude and I
never and and the and the reason why I
always think of the the American male
because I saw that stripper later and
she was like Hey dude I know how it is
uh every guy that comes in here is a hot
blooded American man and I know how to
work it dude and I always think of that
when I think of American or American
male and then I think over her over her
ass dude and we were
laughing when I tell you we were
laughing I said over her ass over her
ass
dude I think about that so much
dude [__] [__] yeah dude he just shot a
load and
[Applause]
just I shot over her ass over her
ass oh man it was so good
dude previously on shooting over her
ass pre
[Laughter]
pre
previous previously on red previously on
hot blooded American
[Music]
mail I said over her over her ass dude
oh God I just love it
man oh just holding on for dear life
just squirting sh clubs are cool